foreign
in Orlando Florida what's up Lynn
how are you Dr Delaney Hardy and what
are you up to
I'm just sitting down here in sunny
Orlando
well just kick us forward actually it's
nice in Nashville today so haha there
you go beautiful what's up
uh well um my call today is really just
based on um I have an adult daughter
um who in the past has been a little bit
um say that again she's been she's been
what a bit deceptive
um
I don't like to say lying but you know
just
um not being completely honest with my
husband and I okay can I stop you right
there I have a bad habit of interrupting
I know I just love to get the data
points like
um
how long
um well she's 25 now and this is
probably when she went off to school
when she was about 18 or 19.
so 19. and where in the world did she
learn
to not say exactly what it is but to
kind of use other words that kind of
were skirted around it a little bit
that's me joking right now because
you're like I don't want to call it a
liar I just want to call her deceptive
it just sounds less I guess you know
yeah in her 18 year old mind like I
wasn't hammered I had like two no I had
two drinks
I'm not I wasn't we weren't sleeping
together Mom I just stayed too late yeah
so she so cook I just want to point that
out go ahead go ahead yes so well I mean
it was more or less just like
um I guess a year of schooling um she
said she was in class and she was not
um she was uh
I guess for her words to you know to us
was that she had this paralyzing anxiety
and couldn't show up in class so what
about that do you not believe because
you don't believe her I could be telling
your voice you don't believe her I I
it's okay if you don't just don't
um I mean I do believe her um just based
on I've had prior to that she did have
an episode when she was younger like
where she did cutting
um not not horrible I guess it's not
good or bad but I mean she did do it she
didn't tell us about it but I did see it
because
um you know I'm pretty observant I have
there's four of them so
um I was you know anyway so I did notice
that she was doing that um brought it up
to her because I saw it um she was very
forthcoming and you know she I took her
to see a therapist and um I guess we I
thought we had moved on I didn't see any
more indication of that she was at the
point you know at that time I thought
she was being very open
um
but then
um anyway so moving forward should they
go to we thought she wanted to go to
school
um we you know prepared for her to do
that as parents do and uh lo and behold
when you know we needed a verification
that she had been in school she had to
come clean so she didn't do it willingly
she just did it because it was basically
by default
um so coming to the present day
um she uh was living in Tallahassee
still
um
another guy while she was there and they
were in a relationship her
um quite some time and just recently she
told us some pretty troubling news which
is quite personal but
um for the sake of just it was not good
and but she was the whole time she was
still lying to us about like what she
was doing and what her life was all
about so we were
I I guess painstaking we were proud of
her because you know from what she
um what she was doing while she was in
school
um you know we were back on that trust
train again trying to
trust her again and then lo and behold
like within like the last couple of
months um you know had that kind of news
um but so
now she's like she got out of it she was
with a boy she was with the boyfriend
and they broke up
um she made some really really bad
financial decisions with him
um very expensive financial decisions
and so she's no longer with him but now
she's with
um a new boyfriend and
um she's doing a lot of behavior like I
said she's you know smoking daily she's
drinking more than she has ever she's
never been a big drinker that I know of
um
and I'm just concerned with her current
debate how old is she Lynn
she's 25.
and you have four other kids where does
she fall what order
she's the oldest oldest
and tell me about Dad
um
just like who he is or what kind of
father he is or okay so he uh
I mean she's a lot like him so I guess
she just you know she's kind of wanted
to tell me about him okay so he doesn't
like to he's kind of likes to live in
Oblivion like if there's you know
there's a lot of issues that he has that
he likes to push him underneath the
carpet
um
such as
maybe you've spent the last 25 years of
your relationship covering up for this
dude I'm asking you just tell me about
him
um
um not emotionally available okay
so but very sensitive like yes yeah yes
okay so I wrote down two words when you
started talking
the two words are connection and
pressure
the behaviors you're describing with
your daughter behaviors I've seen
thousand times working with college
students for two decades
here's what it is it is a young child
screaming
for the two adults in their life in her
life
not to
um
play with although that's a part of but
to connect do you see me
and a disregulated child that is not
fully plugged in
will try to plug into a hundred
different things when you're trying to
plug in that pressure will build and
build and build and I can control it
sometimes through
eating or not eating I can control it
through cutting I can control it through
athletic achievement I can control it
even through Straight A's
It ultimately manifests itself into high
high anxiety
and what makes anxiety go away weed
alcohol
Percocet it stops it for a while until
it kills you
right
buying things what else intimate
relationships
so all of the behavior I mean it's just
she's following a track
the second thing is is
the word sensitive it has such a
negative connotation in our culture
which I just hate I am extra sensitive
to certain things all of us are some
people are extra sensitive to how much
jalapenos they can have in their queso
some are extra sensitive to they walk
into a room and can just feel
something's off
um I have a weird I can walk up to
somebody and look at them and say you're
not okay you don't have to talk to me
about it but I want you to know that I
see you and I care about you and just
I'll walk away nine times out of ten
that person will reach out and be like I
don't know who you are you weird
sorcerer but there's a sensitivity okay
great
when you have an older child who is born
highly sensitive
and then they get the weight of the
family put on them because Dad's
unavailable
it's trying to hold like just think
about holding like workout plates above
your head and your arms start shaking
and shaking and shaking
and so the question is that as a 25 year
old isn't it here's what I'm gonna tell
you she doesn't need any more advice
she doesn't need any more threats or any
more if you just do this is then this
then this is because there's been a
continual
my relationship to you her dad's
relationship to her
um has been contingent on performance
if she doesn't do a thing or she does do
a thing then you get us
you get our money our support our love a
seat at our table
see what I'm saying
I do and so
the only way through it is a complete
and utter reversal of how y'all have
done it and if Dad won't be involved
that's not going to be involved but
she's gonna have to hear you say those
words
he's available but I mean like he like I
don't know how like present but not
available which I think is actually more
caustic to a kid
okay an absent father a father who moves
away I mean you can look at the data
it's it's really damaging but a dad who
sits on the couch and stares off into
space or a dad who stares at his laptop
makes a kid insane because the kid is
wondering what is so great because it's
all relationship for a child that's how
they see the world so they want to know
what is so appealing and beautiful and
wonderful about that laptop that they
don't have
you take a sensitive what is so
important about that client why is that
client so much more beautiful than me
Dad
and she will try to answer that question
forever and ever and ever and when
you're 12 you you don't have any
resources to answer questions and it
just bottles and traps and traps and
traps and traps
and that's when cutting goes it lets
some of the steam out
yeah that's how she described it because
I mean I did you know I mean I we
actually have a very
I mean I
I mean they're always very forthcoming
eventually with me but it's usually when
it's you know
a coming permission like like they don't
hardly have a choice
um you're a conflating relationship with
information
okay y'all get y'all y'all pass
information back and forth to each other
well I know how to take like was if she
says something or if she tells me that
something is her reality or like this is
her situation I don't know to really
trust her because every time that why
I totally trust you I'm not going to
give you any money that's not where
we're at right now
right but I hear you and I'm so
heartbroken for you and you are always
welcome at our house
yes and I believe that they do believe
that because we've had that so many
times I know they
can
um come here and that we're always you
know here to help them I mean
um
I I don't know what this you know she
just does stuff and then she just like
it comes out and you're like well why I
don't understand why you would do that
or why you would think that was okay or
you know what I mean and then
I don't know how can you if I'm not
articulating it correctly but no no
you're articulating it great I'm trying
to think of the right way to say it
um I just want you to look at your
relationship with your oldest daughter
your baby girl
yeah and ask if
a a relational approach of judgment
at all cost what does that got you
I would suggest trying a path of
curiosity and love over judgment she
knows you don't approve of what she's
doing you don't have to keep saying that
right what she's desperate for is you to
take her out for coffee and say I've got
some things I never told you
and you tell her about that boy that was
hurt you deeply before you met her dad
and how hard it has been to be in
relationship with somebody that you love
deeply but who is emotionally absent
and maybe you didn't cut and maybe you
didn't fill in the blank but you did
have some coping strategies because
you've made it this far
and in some ways you've been a single
parent with a guy sitting on the other
end of the couch
you know what she's going through
and sometimes when I see something in my
son I know what he's doing because I did
the exact thing I'm over overzealous
about it because I don't want him to
hurt like I did
and in the process I push him away
because he doesn't have a context for my
pain yet
and so when I say connecting that her
behavior is like more or less because of
the relationship between her like she
has with her dad or
like I mean like is there like I don't
know what I'm saying is you see the
world in cause and effect either or this
because that everything for you is an
algorithm and I'm telling you it's way
more complex than that it so
a thousand different things could have
led to this moment what I'm telling you
at this point is it doesn't matter
I'm telling you is you have a 25 year
old daughter who is desperate to know
her mom and to know that her mom sees
her and loves her and trusts her
because you say my kids know they can
come home
your daughter's Behavior over the last
five years suggests she doesn't know
that or she knows she can come home but
it's not worth it
because we're gonna have to do this and
have all these lectures and discussions
and why are we doing all these things
and I'm not saying those are all bad
what I'm saying is
she needs to know you're a human not a
not in a spreadsheet
that doesn't make sense because the with
everything that's you know going on or
you know I mean I don't make the whole
like I mean we we get together quite
frequently but I don't talk to her about
it I'm if she brings it up I may say
well where are you what you know with
that just you know do you are you making
any Headway you know so you can get out
of that situation so you can move
forward and she's like I just don't want
to talk about it with you right so I
don't know
okay and I just don't know in your mind
first does she know if we're available
there
in your mind
a conversation means you are supporting
her decisions
holding your hand across the table at a
coffee shop and looking in the eyes and
telling her I've never cut but I've done
this
okay I've had to survive too and I'm not
I'm telling you that because I've hidden
this from you because I want to be the
strong one and those days are over now
I love you I love you too much to let
you go through this by yourself
and no I'm not gonna move my values my
values are here because of what I've
experienced
mm-hmm but if all we needed was
um for the good life was a textbook we
would just read one
right yeah but we need relationship
and
I my guess is you and I could talk for
another five hours you've probably had
to turn some of that off in your life to
survive
and not survive not to death but survive
sanity wise
yes you're not wrong about that
and there's a terrifying fear that if
you open that door even a crack to
somebody especially to your daughter
that you will lose control never be able
to close that door back
am I right
you're not wrong
you can't even say it I love it you
can't say the words you are right and I
was wrong
so good what are you pick up on those
things so listen listen yes
here's what your daughter knows
okay okay can I just can I can I just
cut to the chase real direct but I want
to say it that's exactly what I want I
just thought you and I are having fun at
this point okay but I'm being serious
yeah okay your daughter knows you're not
telling the truth too she learned it
from you
okay she learned that we've got to hide
certain things so that we can stay in
relationship with people so that we can
eat so we cannot get hurt so we can stay
safe so that somebody will help us with
our tuition because we can't tell the
full story and we learned it from Mom
because mom had to put part of herself
in a closet so that she could survive
and the only way through that is for you
to open the closet door and show your
daughter a little bit of what's in there
not all the not guts and Gore and all
that kind of stuff
right
but she's got to know her mom knows her
Anne loves her anyway
and I if I'm so here's what I'm telling
you if I'm you I would sit down and have
some sort of conversation about this
I have tried to Love You Through giving
you advice and wisdom for so long those
days are over if you ask me I'm going to
tell you
but I'm going to invite you in I I want
you to know there's always a standing
offer for my wisdom and my advice for
whatever that's worth
from this point forward I want my
daughter back
and I'm gonna go first there are some
stories about me that you don't know
that I want you to know
okay if I can do that can you yes I
actually
try to feed the strong person for your
kids and
sometimes being the strong person is
comes across as highly inauthentic and
deceptive
or to say it another way sometimes the
strongest most powerful thing you can do
there's still somebody I'm not okay
literally like physically speaking the
hardest I've ever been hugged was from
an active seal
he'd gotten back from deployment had
some challenges
and was hugging me so hard I couldn't
breathe
they were weeping so hard they couldn't
that was strength
that was bravery that was power
that's what I'm talking about
and that person's a close friend to this
day
your daughters got all the rules she
knows she's got all the values she knows
and I'm not saying you become a doormat
not at all you hold true to your values
it's time that your daughter got to meet
her mom
and it's time you look in the eye and
say I'm sorry
I didn't know what to do so I went to
rules I went to regulations
and I pushed you away I'm sorry from
this point forward I want my daughter
back